my back here she's got coolant all over
the ground I was just wondering if you
gonna just double up and keep going
around because we're almost here there's
the delivery the delivery good you look
at this thing and you'll come back here
with at least one strap pick this up and
I'll drag you home tonight yeah that's
how we work in pairs we help each other
out you know wherever we need a extra
hand here but today it looks like I'm
gonna be needing the hand to get back
home I don't think we're gonna have time
today to stop and you wrecked everything
but that's alright it adds an extra day
to what we want to be doing but we're
the kind of people that could put out
that extra day
turned out better than I thought
actually and this guy here in one piece
I'll be it a little shaky but we'll
reinforce it again just because we're a
snow machine down don't mean we can't
finish up with what we started we
finished the job now I go back and go
start a new unexpected job little bit of
mechanicing we'll get this home and
we'll call it a day been a long day
already this morning was long enough
this afternoon was long enough but we
still got a 40 mile ride home